ahora haremos algunos ejercicios con
preguntas de los ejercicios de khan
academy sobre el algoritmo estándar nos
pregunta cuál de las siguientes
multiplica correctamente 74 por 8 usando
el algoritmo estándar pausa en el vídeo
y traten de resolverlo antes de que lo
hagamos juntos ok
primero vamos a recordar qué es el
algoritmo estándar es más recordemos
desde que es un algoritmo un algoritmo
es una serie de pasos que podemos
realizar para llegar a hacer algo
probablemente ya han escuchado hablar
del algoritmo informático pero también
podemos tener algoritmos en matemáticas
porque consiste en usar un método para
hacer algo y el algoritmo estándar es la
forma convencional o típica que muchas
personas usan para resolver una
multiplicación o pregunta cómo está pero
como un recordatorio en el algoritmo
estándar si multiplicamos 74 por 8
escribimos 8 en la posición de las
unidades justo abajo del 4 que también
está en las unidades
después multiplicamos cada una de estas
posiciones por ese 8 así que empezamos
con 4 por 8 que nos da 32 y 32 lo
podemos expresar como dos unidades y
tres decenas vamos a ponerlas aquí y
después multiplicamos este 7 por el 8
entonces 7 por 8 156 así que tenemos 56
decenas porque si tenemos 7 decenas por
8 eso nos da 56 decenas más las tres
decenas que ya teníamos nos quedan 59
decenas vamos a escribir 59 decenas así
que al final tenemos 592 ahora si
analizamos las opciones eso es
exactamente lo que tenemos en la opción
c pero vamos a ver cuál fue el error en
las otras dos opciones vamos a ver en la
primera cuando se multiplican cuatro
unidades por ocho unidades de acuerdo a
esto la persona que lo hizo de alguna
forma pensó que eran tres
y dos decenas es decir 23 pero 4 x 8 no
es 23 así que lo descartamos y en esta
opción cuando multiplican 4 enteros por
8 enteros eso debe de ser 32 por eso hay
dos enteros aquí y debería de haber tres
decenas de esa forma cuando se
multiplican siete decenas por ocho queda
56 pero después hay que agregar otras
tres decenas y al final quedan 59 por
eso es que no estuvo bien hagamos otro
ejemplo aquí nos dan otro tipo de
pregunta nos dicen que daniel empieza a
usar el algoritmo estándar para resolver
418 por 5 su trabajo se muestra abajo
con qué número daniel deberá reemplazar
pausa en el vídeo y vean si pueden
resolverlo bueno al principio puede que
los confundan un poco con estas pero lo
que intentan hacer aquí es que entiendan
o mejor dicho que todos entendamos lo
que daniel trata de hacer cuando usa el
algoritmo estándar así que como en el
ejercicio
pasado la forma de resolver esto es con
el algoritmo estándar voy a escribir de
este lado 418 por 5 entonces tenemos 8
enteros por 50 euros que nos da 40
enteros y 40 enteros también lo podemos
escribir como 0 enteros y cuatro decenas
ese es el número que va aquí en el
proceso que danielle no terminó daniel
estaba resolviendo esta multiplicación
pero sólo hizo esta parte y cuando
nosotros lo empezamos a resolver nos
dimos cuenta de que significa esa y la
aie debe de ser un 4 entonces con qué
número daniel deberá reemplazar que él
deberá reemplazarla con un 4 que
representa ya decenas es decir 4 decenas
y claro podríamos seguir resolviendo
esto
danielle podría decir bueno aquí tengo
una decena por 5 que me da 5 decenas más
las otras cuatro decenas eso me dan 9
decenas y al final si daniel quisiera
terminar toda la operación aquí
tiene cuatro centenas y eso por cinco es
igual a veinte centenas que las podemos
escribir como cero centenas y dos
millares o lo podemos ver como veinte
centenas pero no nos están pidiendo que
hagamos toda la operación solamente
queríamos saber qué fue lo que hizo
daniel en el primer paso que el número
debería de haber escrito en lugar de una
y ya vimos que la aie se reemplaza con
un 4 hay un 4 en la posición de las
decenas así que serían 4 decenas